- Est-ce que le directeur
de la gendarmerie trouve conforme
l'image du gendarme
Louis de Funès ?
- Pas tout à fait. Admettons
que c'est un gendarme d'occasion.
- Pas du tout !
- Pas du tout ? Vous contestez ?
D'abord
il s'est collé des galons,
je croyais que vous n'aviez
pas le droit d'être, comme ça,
maréchal des logis-chef
d'entrée de jeu.
Ca, ce n'est pas normal ! Vous
n'avez pas suivi le cursus honorum,
vous n'avez pas d'abord
été gendarme,
et puis après vous avez pris
vos galons. Ca, c'est scandaleux !
- J'aimerais savoir ce qui se passe
maintenant sur la route
quand vous vous faites arrêter
par un gendarme ?
Quand vous croisez un gendarme,
qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit ?
- Que des choses très gentilles
et très charmantes.
[Ils parlent en même temps]
Pardon ?
- Ils sont satisfaits en général de
l'image que vous avez donné d'eux ?
- Je n'ai jamais eu une critique,
je n'ai reçu que des compliments
sur les films.
- Comment êtes-vous
devenu gendarme ?
Comment avez-vous fait pour vous
mettre dans la peau d'un gendarme ?
- C'est d'après
une idée de Balducci,
qui lui, se promenait,
paraît-il, à Saint-Tropez,
et il y avait, paraît-il,
un gendarme assis à califourchon
sur sa chaise devant la gendarmerie,
et ça m'étonnerais qu'elle était là.
- Mais ce n'est pas contraire
au règlement ?
- Je ne sais pas,
il était assis là,
et ça c'est la version de Balducci,
qui nous a donné une bonne source,
et il a dit :
"M., j'aimerais déposé plainte, on
m'a volé ma caméra dans ma voiture."
Le gendarme lui répond : "Pfff... On
vous a volé votre caméra ?" "Oui."
"C'est embêtant... Vous tenez
à faire une déposition ?"
"Mais oui,
c'est une Beaulieu, une 16 mm."
"Bah oui, on sait qui c'est.
On arrive pas à l'attraper...
"Tiens, regardez-le là-bas, c'est
lui qui vous a volé votre caméra !"
Mais il n'avait pas de preuves,
on a jamais pu l'attraper !
- Mais la gendarmerie avait l'oeil
quand même, vous voyez.
- Mais "Les Gendarmes" sont partis
d'une petite histoire comme ça.
- Mais comment vous êtes-vous mis
dans la peau d'un gendarme ?
Avez-vous vécu avec
des brigades de gendarmerie ?
- Ah non, non.
- Ca viendra plus tard peut-être,
quand on va le mobiliser.
- Non, mais on a un peu joué sur
ce qu'on connaissait des gendarmes.
- Mais ils ne se comportent
pas tous comme vous, quand même !
- Si, ils sont gentils comme nous,
on est une brigade très gentille.
- A Saint-Tropez ?
- Non, la nôtre !
Et celle de Saint-Tropez est encore
plus charmante, et très gentille.
Et je voulais dire un mot aussi
pour leur chef, Olivier,
qui est un charmant garçon.
- C'est une recommandation
pour l'avancement ?
- Je veux bien !
C'est vous qui me le suggérez.
Et je voulais dire aussi
un bonjour
aux gendarmes d'Oudon,
et aux gendarmes d'Ancenis,
qui sont des charmants garçons.
Car j'ai eu une affaire judiciaire,
à l'époque, avec un maître-chanteur...
Une histoire horrible !
Et grâce à eux,
j'ai pu dormir tranquille
parce qu'ils couchaient chez nous.
Il y en a un qui faisait la ronde
avec une mitraillette,
c'était le lieutenant Cégers,
qui est un charmant garçon aussi.
- Ca fait déjà beaucoup de monde
qui sera heureux !
- Vous étiez presque dans le film,
avec les gendarmes couchant
autour de vous.
- Je crois qu'il a de noirs dessins
pour demain.
- Ils veulent vous rencontrer
paraît-il,
dans votre prochain film.
- Dans un prochain projet !
- Oui, j'en ai entendu parler.
- Dans le dernier gendarme, oui.
- Toujours le dernier, d'ailleurs.
- Mais le film débuterait comme ça :
il y aurait des motards
qui viendraient chez M. Galabru,
par exemple, mais avec le nom
"Galabru", lui déposer un pli.
Un autre motard qui vient chez
De Funès, chez Grosso, chez Modo,
chez... Christian Marin,
et nous on se réunit, on se retrouve
à la direction de la gendarmerie.
- Elle a déménagé, je vous signale.
- Oui, je l'ai reçue !
- Ah bon, parfait !
- Vous êtes mobilisé alors ?
- Non, non !
- Il reçoit un savon d'abord.
- Ca doit être une décoration.
- N'allons pas jusque là !
- Dans le film !
Et il y aura un acteur
qui fera M. le directeur,
il y aura des généraux, on nous
fait asseoir, et on nous dit :
"Dites-moi M. De Funès
et M. Galabru,
"je voulais vous demander..."
Ca, ce sera un général qui parle.
"Je voulais vous demander,
M. le directeur.
"Est-ce que
vous vous foutez de nous ?"
- Je ne parle pas comme ça, moi.
- Non, non.
Et il s'habille
en militaire très dur.
- Ca n'existe pas dans
les gendarmes. Mais supposons.
- "Vos films sont mal fichus ! Quelle
image vous faites des gendarmes ?
"M. De Funès, moi, je ne vous aime
pas du tout comme acteur..."
- Oh, je n'oserais pas vous dire
une chose pareille, voyons !
- Ce serait une chose comme ça,
et on nous mettrait d'office pendant
un mois, tous, dans la gendarmerie !
- Voilà, je le disais,
vous allez finir par...
- Alors avec les chiens,
les hélicoptères, les chars,
toute la grande gendarmerie.
- Il ne vous arrivera
pas malheur, alors ?
- Je ne sais pas.
- On verra !